voilà mon premier jour en france la gare
de l'est
j'arrive jusque là au 27 mai 2015 je
suis arrivé à paris par les gars de
l'est
après trois ans du voyage le moment
qu'ils occupaient série en 2012
la voilà je suis à paris mais je crois
pas que je suis arrivé je suis toujours
au monde du voyage
est ce que je suis en france
est ce que le voyage se termine heures
ou pas encore et finalement heureusement
il ya des potes qui marie mahmoud saïd
madi madiot je suis là je suis un peu
calmé je suis hors gérer santé qui a je
suis existe là je viens de sortie voilà
c'est ça les bâtiments aux soins que je
connais
est-ce que c'est paris c'est de france
et après gare de l'est je suis arrivée
juste là à la caf et rouge la patache je
suis a pris mon premier set de fromage
ici aujourd'hui le var et les fermer
mais le jour que je suis venu ici il
rentable ici je vais manger ici avec mes
amis quand je suis tourné il ya un grand
fan de là-bas avec des équipes de
photographes qui en train de prendre de
photos avec des super beau vêtement est
là c'est ma santé c'est ça les classes
parisien je suis arrivée et après qu'on
a partie de la barre
on a pris la voiture l'impasse et baba
baisse pour chercher un ami j'étais là
dans un quartier parisien barbès j'étais
choquée de trouver du sucre comme ça il
ya tous les odeurs les épices les viande
des légumes
c'était surprise pour moi parce que
comme je dis j'ai pas imaginer paris
comme ça je sais pas cette image de
paris mais à l'intérieur c'est quelque
chose différent aujourd'hui à des
polices et timo normalement il ya des
gens qui met des trucs par terre qui
vendent des épices des légumes sans vrai
saut comme je suis un look r comme je
suis en temps quelques pas avant de
damas
et même ses écrits en arabe après cette
longue voyage je suis allé chez un pote
pour j'avais besoin de prendre douche
pour dormir un peu et pas préparé le
lendemain pour demander l'asile et à la
préfecture de police
j'étais vraiment choqué je suis venu ici
à cinq heures du matin et un coût énorme
mot ici sur 150 personnes j'ai pris ma
place ici j'avais attendait de 5 heures
du matin jusqu'à 8 or pour les bureaux
étaient ouverts et le moment je suis
arrivé à l'intérieur c'était 10h 10h30
j'ai demandé à la mission quitter la
barre un policier avant lé commencé
d'écrire je comprends pas qu est ce qu
elle a dit mais c'était tous les traités
comme des moutons va là bas va lavalas à
gauche mais je sais pas quoi et il m'a
dit toi tu veux quoi tu as un rendez
vous je dis non j'ai pas en rendez vous
et je parle en anglais quand même je dis
je suis venu pour demander l'asile et
comment je prends rendez vous il faut
que tu parle français monsieur je parle
pas le français monsieur je parle
anglais je suis arrivé hier
il faut que tu vas en rendez vous allez
vas-y vas-y et je suis parti sans savoir
qu'est ce que je fais et ça posait des
questions de ma tête est-ce que ça
mérite d'être ici au pas ç'a pris six
mois pour avoir un rendez-vous avec le
prat
si moi je suis en un temps est ce que tu
veux recevoir les résident au pas ce que
j'ai le droit de rester en france repart
avec un petit récit pis si un petit
papier qui m'a ne permet pas de
travailler
j'ai beau que jamais oublier les guerres
en série j'arrive pas oublier le voyage
que je fais j'arrive pas à comprendre
comment j'ai été forcé de quitter mon
pays
et oui j'ai avance je mens tigréat j'ai
mes amis français je parle aujourd'hui
les français je vis à paris
mais quand même mort il ya un moment à
fin de soirée quand je suis sur mon lit
il ya un petit et un petit scénario un
petit voyage qui passe très vite dans ma
tête
quel est guère les voyages ma famille
l'ancien mes amis et ma vie quand
j'étais en séries mais j'ai dit quand
même merci que je suis là merci pour les
françaises merci pour mes amis merci
pour qui m'a aidé pour être ici et eau
pour être un chef cuisinier en poupe nu
et là je vous bien qu'ils jouent à
partager ma culture partagée à mon bon
cuisine en retour